[Musique]
c'est déjà presque de l'histoire
le chlordécone un pesticide interdit aux
états unis dès 1976 et qui des relations
en trafic de lobbyisme agricole en
ministre complaisant sera saupoudrait
sur les plantations martiniquaise et
guadeloupéenne des années 70 jusqu'à
parfois début 2010 une île hectares de
terres agricoles polluées 56% des cours
d'eau les trois quarts des aliments
contaminés 600 ans avant d'en être
débarrassé mais dans 600 ans
quel sera l'état de santé de la
population cancer prématurité troubles
cognitifs l'épreuve des méfaits du
pesticide s'accumulent face à cela la
réaction des autorités semblent faire fi
du principe de précaution
c'est déjà presque de l'histoire
mais si le scandale du chlordécone était
devant nous
[Musique]